les amis nous avons 1930 nous sommes une
femme qui s'appelle scarlett qui
travaillent pour un journal qui
s'appelle the women are all williams est
l'un des acteurs en chef de ce journal à
savoir le boss et nous devons trouver
dans les archives de ce journal de quoi
le mettre derrière les barreaux et je
parle pas de lui que tu as le matin le
vent ok c'est parti il enquête commence
bandeau rica et c'est un jeu français
ouais ouais moi je suis français je suis
fier c'est parti pour la plus grande
enquête
nous sommes de ceux qui mentent de ceux
qui joueront ne pas le faire nous sommes
de ceux dont il faut se méfier de ceux
dont on prononce le nom avec mépris de
ceux qui vous sont indispensables nous
sommes de ceux qui se disent différents
nous sommes de ceux qui disent de faire
attention à la parole à l'information
aux rumeurs et nous sommes ceux qui les
répandent
nous sommes ceux qui croient en vous les
intermédiaires médiocres
nous sommes la parole l'information et
les rumeurs et nous mentons au [ __ ] ça
plus entendu france au genre est dans un
jeu vidéo surtout une cible voit un tut
est convaincu que tu pourrais changer la
face du monde en écrivant sur des
banquiers et des politiciens dont tout
le monde se fout et tu nous a convaincus
aussi toujours n'a de marche mais pas
tant que tu l'avais espéré trente ans
que tu l'avais espéré
et maintenant tu te demandes pourquoi tu
as eu un jour besoin de nous moi
peut-être puisque je pouvais voilée à
mes parents tes précieux document mais
les autres purs besoin de crédit
comment peux tu dire des choses
pareilles parce qu'elles sont évidentes
aaron tu divagues le lan nous sommes
sept à dix vallier
elle joue bien [ __ ] on est loin d'un
connard de squeeze là on va avoir cinq
jours pour trouver des preuves pour
montrer carl williams est un gros fdp
qui mérite la prison voici l'interface
du jeu j'ai trouvé de quoi
décridibiliser aaron avant qu'ils
n'agissent pudiquement les journaux des
archers ne me sens pas d'une grande aide
mais ils m'aideront à me souvenir de ce
que nous faisions à l'époque de leur
publication
et si je commençais par chercher voilà
on a on a donc ici des documents
celui-là celui qu'on vient de voir ok
donc là y'a écrit absolument n'importe
quoi et rhin à lire un document est égal
en gros à une vidéo d'archivé ici on
peut marquer des notes si on en a besoin
c'est faux a ici ben voilà on peut
déplacer les documents pour les trier
dans l'ordre qui nous importe est à 23
éléments à trouver comment on fait pour
découvrir de nouveaux éléments on tape
tout simplement un mot clé on va
commencer par le nom du rédacteur chef
doublé ma pipe c'est pas grave si ce pas
à aaron williams ok échec jusque là on a
des petites cartes qui résume le rôle de
la personne au sein du journal donc je
pense déjà le prix un truc à faire c'est
de marquer chaque nom employé dans la
barre de recherche
pour en savoir un peu plus sur eux voyez
à l'ancien melia rien n'a beaucoup un
[ __ ] ça est une longue vidéo mais
franchement on va vivre une sorte de
[ __ ] de film ça va être cool ok on va
regarder la vidéo qui est apparue en
tapant are all williams dans la
recherche un marché ici
non merci enfin oui c'est bizarre a
précisé pourquoi ça je m'attendais même
pas une réponse
ce n'est pas comme si nous étions très
grandes structures et il a décidé aussi
longtemps que nécessaire
ok ok donc ce mec rencontre l'équipe du
journal pour la première fois ils
s'attendaient pas une réponse et il en a
une
donc mater ce qu'on a pas sa petite
carte à amath matthew wins mais ok
matthew wind jamais rien mac à ok avec
ça on a déjà vu ça y est vous avez trois
trucs on commence par quoi donc ça c'est
logiquement la suite de la scène comme
edward va commencer par ça bah ouais
avez vous lu la lettre aux lecteurs
ils ont répondu nous retournons donc à
notre premier travail
le tri comment sont confirmés les
sources analysé effet séparé le public
du privé
nous ne rendons publique que ce qui doit
l'être et à prat et qui plus est jugé
que ce jeu vous
matt ne vous connais sont à peine il
serait malhonnête de notre part de
remettre un inconnu et les documents
comme on a accepté de confier
mais s'il nous a écrit sénat pour nous
aider je ne pense pas qu'il soit inutile
aaron et la reconnaissance je ne sais
pas comment vas tu as pu tenir ces
montants
d'accord donc le gall grave direct
l'aide de maths ok ok ok ok cette
situation là on l'a jamais vue et
l'autre non plus on dirait une sorte
aurait une réelle celle-là avant est ce
que ne sonne pas sensé 2 ne serait ce
qu'une raison à notre démission là
dedans all the witcher je n'ai pas su
quoi écrire c'était visant jeu tu as
prostituées ton image pour aaron toile
en ce qu'il a fait croire qu'il est
embauché pour analyser des chiffres
alors qu'il exploitait pour recopier
dimitri il ya oublié 15 ans d'amitié
paul encre de son journal
twilight a privé de thé droit
d'expression élémentaire quand atou amat
il s'agit des pâtres infiniment donc
matt c'est bio l'engin battu l'as fait
un vrai truc de poutres et du coup ici
la lettre de démission sans me dire
pourquoi des messieurs mettre un
criminel oui à ce prix on sait que c'est
un criminel non c'est parce qu'il a fait
quoi [ __ ] j'ai hâte de trouver
heureusement que j'ai un inspecteur
réputé est là je sais que vous avez
envie de savoir ce qui s'est passé
vous êtes comme moi mode on va taper le
nom du journal boa
ça se veut être la suite de la réunion
continue comme s'il avait besoin et vous
voulez vraiment lui et ses 2 revenge
c'est un instrument dangereux
nous sommes les derniers probablement
encore à s'en rendre compte
j'ai une comprendre à sion n'ont jamais
ça fait de la messe basse au méliès que
vous voudriez faire couler le rivage
oui c'est une bonne idée ok ce n'est pas
comme si tu m'avais si le choix d'accord
qu'ils démissionnent tous et ils veulent
en plus de sa sphère bid et le journal
des arts and ok on va s'organiser
contrairement à quand tu fais tes
devoirs mercredi on va les classer par
scène comme ça voilà il ya peut-être un
document qui viendra compléter cette
partie de l'histoire à noël situation
est nouvelle situation commençons par
celle ci déjà
et ensuite barreaux noirs c'était le
quid tiens c'était van chi ça
sérieusement la pire à ce une bonne idée
mais oui oui tu te souviens pas tu veux
qu'on te jettent des pierres entre les
pirates et on concède comme on disait tu
déjà en body et une chaudière de
monsieur nier anne bonny il a le geste
aussi beaucoup les pirates
combien faut-il te payer on ne l'atteint
donc ça sera mon vraiment à la création
du journal je pense y chercher un nom
pour le truc alors on va faire ce que
j'ai dit au début on va marquer le nom
de chaque mech un par un et voit surtout
dimitri kg dimitri année un troisième
morceau de la réunion ça m'intéresse à
et comment tu peux aussi prendre sa
place mais encore ce que scarlett a dit
tout à l'heure sur chacun d'entre vous
le concept d'art n'étaient absolue mais
pas au sein de sa propre équipe
il a menti je ne dis pas qu'il faut
aller tout votre tâche et aux boks
j'adore bord qui ne s'agit pas de créer
une polémique
mais un scandale pour nous il nous faut
des preuves font sans confie-t-on sa
plomberie ce ton image al shater boxe je
vais mettre dans les notes et on ira
voir ça juste après avoir maté toutes
les vidéos qui nous a donné ça là on n'a
pas vu non plus regarder c'est la suite
ah non c'est pas la suite c'est un autre
paquet à 6 alors qu'est ce que c'est
c'est sûr que tu n'avais jamais
rencontré et je ne suis même pas si
j'étais à new york cet été 1 tu sais que
je me souvenais même plus d'être venu
j'avais 15 16 ans tu as et combien je
crois que je n'ai même pas encore de
barbe et unasur pas de barbara hren
espèce de béton par l'opa et tout
exemple que c'était avant que tu
commences son premier roman écrit
pourquoi penses tu que je souhaite ici
mais défendue à mourir si personne mais
on forme les articles d'ap oui
si tu me répète encore une fois de faire
attention aux conjonction de
coordination pour que les 13 plus clair
je te jure à rome je vais te tuer a tant
fait pas des maîtrise au moins la
troisième fois qu'ils m'expliquent que
la police que j'ai choisi pour le titre
non ce n'est pas en confiance plus
d'écriture hockey par la police non ok
donc lui il est chargé de rédaction
d'accord auquel un bon poste quand même
dimitri on n'oublie pas ta leur
chatterbox on va on va se le chercher au
[ __ ] et mireille actuelle du nouveau
là on à la suite de la réunion [ __ ] ça
ça me plaît ça signifie qu'il faut aller
vite
le seul endroit où on peut trouver des
preuves tangibles ce sont les archives
du journal
ce que tu as toujours ton contact tu
viens montrer but de joe hockey ou bien
je te fais à remettre avant ce soir le
nom du dossier que tu lui remettra par
coursier aux tribus un ok c'est encore
un autre truc qui va falloir qu'on
cherche et et mais du coup on sait pas
qui c'est on n'a pas vu encore bon alors
moi je suis intéressé par chatr box
voulez vous les rapporter un truc à
chatr boc souvenez vous je suis curieux
de voir qui est shader box une première
vidéo qu'est d'imaginer je te connais je
ne te connais pas qu'on sait c'est
nouveau personnes max quelquefois dans
un commandeur aussi journée mémorable
c'est d'autres journaux ces officines
qui s'enchaînent aux grilles du sénat
pour défendre le droit des femmes des
noirs je ne sais quoi entre 200 et de la
haute
bien sûr je cite l'article celle que
l'on photographie la seule nuit de
l'année où elle vomit son whisky comme
si elle le faisait tout le temps bon
très bien les présentations sont faites
si tu liras c'est avant tout parce
qu'elle est gentille
ensuite parce qu'on peut lui faire
confiance ok puis parce qu'elle est
intelligente et qu'elle connaît du monde
ouais bien sûr parce que c'est une
innovatrice mais que je te passe
quelques années mon droit de la femme
denner un dépôt programme d'intégration
pour les immigrés elle est merveilleuse
philanthrope sans arrière pensée
son image est parfaite pour la ligne
éditoriale mon image je crois que tu
voulais faire un journal qui ne
révèlerait que la vérité par les images
c'est quand même un petit peu le début
d'un mensonge non au wok avec lui
reprendre cette meuf qui a une très très
bonne image pour pouvoir me taux tout en
façon incognito bon donc qu'est ce que
c'est que ça scarlets
tu fais poser que la guibole tout le
monde l'épousé café veulent c'est
n'importe quoi
je n'ai qu'un c'est l'amour il est vieux
son aide et j'allais voir cet homme adam
temps tout au plus alors j'ai 25 ans et
je suis déjà une antiquité et qui lâcha
clark qui veulent qu'elles veulent avoir
réglé la mire chaque année cet homme est
un saint-émilion
elles sont uniquement parce qu'elle va
rencontrer les gens contribuent pas
aussi j'ai besoin d'un port et pourquoi
moi je n'ai jamais rencontré qui avait
refusé de lever parce que les déjeuners
qu'à l'autre bout de la ville où que
papa et mobilier me prenne sa défense
mais si tu es plutôt le genre de votre
père à ils sont frère et soeur ces deux
là ok j'ai noté quoi d'autres tribunes
on a que le truc de tout à l'heure
[ __ ] c'est là que ça devient compliqué
ah non on n'a pas encore noté tous les
berceaux d'avoir de recherche eole en
dolce à ça on n'a pas vu dans des
registres de démission j'ai reçu
compréhensible d'un homme dont j'ai cru
un instant qui se faisait passer pour le
fils jack williams je n'avais rien à
faire c'est je vois là alors je suis
venu rendez-vous des registres de
démission tu te rends compte au moins
dix ans cet homme a fait l'armée est
monté au grade de capitaine a fait du
droit est rentré dans la police est
partie investir en bourse cet homme a
des contacts dans tous les milieux les
plus inaccessibles au règlement des
questions embaucher les gens vont le
voir les adresses
mais cet homme être discret pourquoi
voulait discret ok donc alan doyle est
chargée de communication c'est un mec
qui pèse qu'un système du contact hockey
lotte eisner
mais rien sur l mathieu on a déjà vu
dimitri on a déjà vu
si l on a déjà vu avant on a déjà vu ça
là on est dans la merde moi le seul truc
qui me fait bizarre c'est le mec
matelassé un docteur c'est quoi j'ai pas
bien compris on sait rien de lui regarde
et il est rentré en 1933 et on sait même
pas ce que c'est son rôle c'est bizarre
faudrait que je prenne les notes pour ne
rien oublier sa tenue et je fais que des
recherches timide tu sais pas qui tu
parles gamine scarlett aaron à y en a
qu'on n'a pas vu [ __ ] je ne comprends
pas quoi le journal marche bien tout le
monde le lit les propositions d'articles
affluent en quoi mérite t'il le nom de
choses tu cours après du top qui des
vérités unique
tu t'es enfermé en toi même ton journal
du pourrait quasiment le faire seul tu
sais à quoi notre cerveau à te donner du
crédit à donner confiance aux gens alors
pour et qu'il n'y a pas qu'un seul
esprit à juger de ce qu'on leur fait
lire un seul esprit c'est dangereux
c'est suspect alors que 8,8 rouve que
l'information passe épreuve de la
critique je suis le rédacteur en chef
ça me parait maures qui occupèrent
rédacteur en chef tu veux un cannois que
le contrôle est à cours de récréation
tout ce qui s'en sortent et que les gens
croient que tu contrôles le monde depuis
son bureau
tu n'as pas idée de ce que nous devons à
durer mais moi tu pense à moi tu imagine
ce que moi jean durand quoi aaron c'est
toi qui a voulu tout ça aux îles me
souvenir de ça il faut que je trouve
autre chose au donc avant il y avait un
certain jack est avec toi en chef et
harold la remplacer
d'accord allez jack jack up la bêta vous
être eu suffisamment documents
importants aujourd'hui voulait ouvrir la
journée ok elle n'atteint les archives
ne sont pas assez complexe je veux les
voir il revient d'avoir quelques
documents chez elle ouais très bonne
idée mof jour 2 tout le monde sauf à
renard n'a que cinq jours en jours à
peine séparent parfois rien merci de
m'avoir apporté tous à amy tu n'as rien
trouvé hier
disons qu'à la recherche prendra plus de
temps que prévu j'espère que ce que j'ai
emmené servir
il y à des journaux et un gramophone
j'ai cru me souvenir qu'il y avait des
disques dans les archives né disque oui
de ses interviews qu'on avait faite avec
un run il ya un ou deux ans
le premier d'un gramophone mais j'ai
bien peur que nous devions squido reste
ici ok ok merci merci merci ca drame ce
nom mais pas trop difficile à porter je
le considère comme un avantage
j'ai hérité du nom mon père comme j'ai
hérité du commandeur du commandeur
pourriez-vous éclairer nos auditeurs sur
votre choix de le fermer
autre père avait bâti un empire ge de
malice tic et vous avez décidé de tout
reprendre à zéro avec un nom comme celui
de williams on ne pense jamais tout à
fait à 0 on entend partout c'est
l'impression d'être dans son ombre
j'aurais simplement aimé pouvoir montrer
que j'étais capable d'en faire autant
que lui c'est pour cela que j'ai eu
besoin d'un défi j'ai pris un média et
je vais ramener à son concept de base
mais qui met diallo de hockey ça marche
donc ce journal avait un père s'appelle
the grinder il l'a fait fermer pour
ouvrir revenge ne se fâchera que c'est
jack du coup l'ancien acteur chef chez
barthes ap jack williams et j'ai obtenu
un cd je ne veux pas le journalisme est
ce une affaire journal ok donc le
journal avant devait s'appeler le
hamoniste sais pas quoi espoir pour
trouver and bones revenge on va voir
s'il ya pas quelque chose alors on l'a
déjà vu [ __ ] il devait s'appeler comme
ça avant du couvent et maintenant c'est
juste du rivage en tapant moss j'ai émis
trois oui j'ai entendu dire
sassus d'interviews entendu pas le but
c'était si étrange de devoir travailler
avec lui pour moi il n'était que cet
homme bizarre aux cheveux longs que mon
mari à vitesse de temps en temps à dîner
maintenant maintenant j'ai compris que
c'était le parfait collagen il s'occupe
de la comptabilité du rivage surtout
brillé entre les lignes de rôle d
interminables
mais pas que tu peux taper un mot une
combinaison cherché hier puisqu'il ya
nouveau journée aujourd'hui à nouvelle
vie dans à taper le nom de johnny tu ne
penses pas que le journal doit être plus
engagé c'est à dire qu'ils devraient à
l'avenir voter comme juni le faisait
avant mais ce n'est pas ce que nous
faisons déjà
c'est bien sûr directement mais je parle
de manière plus frontale tu sais quel
point aaron tient à ce que l'on ne
touche à rien tout ce qui compte c'est
de publier les documents au litre on
pourrait ne pas savoir se servir d'un
stylo qu'il ne le remarquerait pas il
serait peut-être temps de changer ça non
m j'aime le principe mais c'est ce qui
fait l'unicité du journal dévoilée juste
dévoilé voilà on voit c'est wikileaks
wallard truc qui prennent des documents
que des gens trouvaient les publie en
vérifiant que ce sont des vrais bons
mètres à la voie à la grappe à vue nous
ne pouvons pas attendre éternellement du
s'est alors pas qu'est ce que tu en
penses
je pense comme alan à expliquer de quoi
il s'agit de maths leur a un peu perdu
nous réfléchissons disons à la ligne
éditoriale du prochain numéro il est
très difficile pour nous d'avancer sans
savoir quelles sortes d'articles nous
avons publié cet avion comment dire ça
sent que c'est l'herne campagne
politique
nous avons reçu l'image même de la
pauvreté aux états unis la masse du
chômage
nous ne sommes plus face à une poignée
de mafieux qui se font la guerre entre
eux nous sommes tous concernés
toute la rue les tongs surveille on se
moque de nous pourrions peut-être fait
réagir le nouveau président qui n'en a
sûrement pas besoin après tout mais ce
que je dis ne concerne pas uniquement
les états unis nous avons reçu des
documents militaires sur l'économie
européenne de sources anti impérialiste
américaine nous avons apporté beaucoup
de choses d'europe la pauvreté également
mais aussi des inquiétudes sur le
nouveau chancelier allemand tu penses
que j'ai fait peur un match gens-là amok
non un run en revanche ça n'a pas servi
à grand chose
il n'a jamais voulu publier sur hitler
hitler
voilà un truc rôle enquête avance un peu
mais là on est là je pense la phase la
plus dure on a un peu dans le flou et
tous à devenir clair dans pas trop
longtemps je pense au québec soit encore
comme cents rationne la gamme je crois
que je ne voulais pas publié sur les
couleurs c'est très différent et fils
incendie du reichstag et la suspension
des droits civils élémentaires les
choses deviennent graves
je crois que nous sommes fourvoyés dans
cette histoire de monarchie enfin que
les monarchistes allemands se sont
fourvoyés que nous aurions dû voir qu
hitler ne ferait qu à sa tête il est en
train de monter des sortes de prison des
prix
mais quand vous travaillez pour les
opposants politiques je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment les allemandes
peuvent ne pas être au courant
enfin mais on sa mère crédit
ils ont vraiment des deux c'est
wikileaks mais à l'époque quoi du coup
wikileaks sous forme de journal du métré
ya du nouveau
oui tout le monde en veut nous ne fuyons
pas nous lâcher prise tu nous as trop
qu'il y aurait autant alors gollob
j'aimerais encore aller au théâtre que
nous ne soyons plus des lincoln en
puissance que nous franchissions la
porte du monde réel et nous rendions
compte que nous n'existons pas en ce
temps j'aimerais avoir vu les cinq actes
émouvant et que nous fassions encore
semblant de savoir que ce n'est que de
la fiction que tu ramasses encore mes
affaires pour moi mais j'ai eu mal
mais quand ma cape et que nous sortirons
nous promener et que nous nous
disputions pour rien et que je te
reproche sa puérilité que cette même
curité me fasse rire te fasse pardonner
mais il semblerait que tu sois devenu un
adulte trop sérieux trop responsable
pour ça c'était parce que tu as voulu
dire quand tu affirmer quoi des gens que
vous avez trop ignorée qu'est ce qu'il
te faut faire un exemple concret
professionnels la tentative de démission
de dimitri s'intéresser à lui une
semaine tout au plus parce qu'il a
essayé de quitter cette chose dans
lesquels tu nous as embarquée ouaga qui
a déjà tenté de ketele délire à dimitri
l'a voulu ce bar et le bon dimitri
auquel je reproche à aaron de trop snobé
son équipe deux pas du tout faire
attention à l'odre 200 voire ne sont
tamponnés les couilles pour l'année dans
la merde on est dans la phase où j'ai
tapé tous les prénoms de l'équipe de
lavardens chercher ça n'a rien donné
[ __ ] mais justement pas ils parlent
tous hyper mal du journal alors que pour
le moment ça n'a pas l'air si désastreux
quoi et je comprends pas pourquoi j'aime
pas savoir qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'il
soit embarqué dans un truc qui leur
plaît vraiment pas à part le fait car on
a un comportement de connard je vois pas
pourquoi ils ont des réactions comme ça
la ja c'est qu'on n'a pas écouté sur
aaron dire que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
les mettre en oeuvre ou non plus sur
comment vidéo
je pense par utopie je pense que rien
n'est impossible et que rien n'est
jamais fixé à la les chiens on pense que
l'alphabet n'est pas dans le bon ordre
des couleurs à découvrir l'histoire et
écrire je pense qu'il faut avoir peur et
c'est sûr monter soi même
et ben moi je pense que tu m'as pas
vraiment donné de mot clé forcément tu y
avoir des informations utiles dans les
interviews pour retrouver les journaux
merci pour l'un 10 j'ai tapé
journalistes ça va donner un journal
qu'on n'avait pas le principe ça c'est
la suite ce n'est pas les principes de
tout journal que de dire la vérité
en théorie oui mais il ya toujours des
accords d information d affaires à
dissimuler les particuliers n'ose plus
rien koffi aux journalistes qu est-ce
qui serait différent cette fois ci ne me
dis pas que le commandeur n'avait pas
pour but de livrer la vérité aux
lecteurs ça ne fonctionnera pas d'être
parent nous aurons peut-être un nouveau
come under c'est même très probable
tu me demandes d'assister à l'une des
plus grandes réussites journalisme ou à
l'un de ses plus grands échecs
il y aura entre deux est ce que je serai
prête à me donner les archives des
archives volées les archives de sa
famille on l'a vu un hôpital on a vu une
vidéo elle dit tu m'as fait voler les
archers de ma famille [ __ ] j'ai envie
de ça ce que ces fameuses j'archive là
j'ai tapé le mot peur et deux nouveaux
journaux mon gars dont une situation
qu'on ne connaît pas encore [ __ ] c'est
bien ça ne fonctionne pas mais si tu me
la lettre ne fonctionnait pas si nous
n'avions pas de réponse est bien journée
à s'arrêterait qu'est ce que tu aimerais
qu passion tous ceux de notre entourage
susceptibles d'avoir des dossiers ont eu
peur et nous ont tourné le dos je
comprends même pas après la matiz fait
chier et tous ces chants dont nous parle
ce n'est pas toi qui disais qu ne
risquions lien disons la vérité
je sais de quoi tu perds des doigts
forme ces histoires voilà jusqu'en
amérique centrale
tu crois vraiment qu'il sortira de son
trou pour venir se venger a pas peur de
force
il a peur des procès oui il y avait
sûrement raison d'en avoir peur et doit
avoir un [ __ ] de procès est là on va
taper les douars fort des bons gars
c'est la femme en quête la chance va
devrait se voir des trucs
oui oui oui à sa suite c'est que la
station je sais je n'ai jamais dit je
les analyse écouter et l'autre ford
n'est qu'un exemple parmi tout ce que
j'ai pu trouver les tiroirs de patates
sont remplis de ces documents
je voudrais faire un commandeur et
ouvrir au journal
ok un jour elle subirait tous à tous ses
secrets cachés confidentiel aux lecteurs
de d'accord un journal pure vérité du
terrain est historique
ok mais dites moi qu'est ce que vous en
pensez que c'est bien à la leurs
discussions afin de créer pense que
c'est stupide
tu monsieur monde est ce que tu feras si
je te dis je suis donc obligé de dire
oui mais je ferais si je suis au bureau
n'a toujours été doué pour te faire dire
oui mais il me regarda chaque fois avec
son herbe
bon allez il faut qu'on continue à
chercher plutôt aux approches là ça on
commence à tout relié dans leurs bras
j'ai pas vu ça combien 3 400 scarlett on
a beaucoup donné aussi peut-être s'en
sent qu'elle il faut retrancher le tri
secondes perdues document je crois que
vous savez comment c'est oui pour passer
de plus de 1000 à l'abandon pour le
moment de dresser une maquette de
premier numéro on doit se mettre
d'accord sur une peine qui soit
suffisamment frappante aux cartes les
doigts fort oui nous avons retrouvé une
lettre datant de 26 à dresser du
gouvernement mon père lui demandant de
suivre le mouvement médiatique qui
annonçait que ford était mort dans un
incendie qui avait détruit toutes les
informations potentiel sur son réseau
ford ont été envoyés en amérique du sud
sous une fausse identité et apparemment
il y serait toujours je suppose que
l'incendié des ventes à 5 évidemment m'a
tapé incendie financier mcclintic ford
aurait changé sa liberté et la
destruction des preuves de sa
culpabilité contre tous les noms qui
composaient son réseau au quai à angers
de l'achat de tabac aux états unis parce
qu'apparemment il s'est réfugié aux
états unis ou en aval du sud chez paco
l'aubois je tapais tajine lambert de
recharge et je tombe sur un document
qu'on n'a pas encore vu je suppose
epic yarn je ne suis pas une secrétaire
tu feras la collection toi-même la
prochaine fois que nous devrons revenir
sur le prénom de leurs enfants
pour tout résumer bat il s'agit d'un
document venons d'offrir cette ville aux
états unis nous avons tout le monde car
il y apparaît message que peu nos
sources nous fournissent un certain jean
je m'autorise ombret dénonciation dame
georges mont-laurier bancaires sur des
comptes de personnes fraîchement décédé
disons que ça a commencé la meilleure
partie de l'histoire c'est que l'auteur
de la fnac et empêcher woods un mois
après rue à craindre et aggrave le
problème de le publier
le problème c'est que nous et quand
j'étais sage et dire tout le monde sauf
aaron voudrions retranché au document la
liste des arnaques et monsieur refus
sous prétexte que modifier un document
c'est le trahir ouvrait la porte à tous
les débordements et je te laisse
imaginer la suite
je les bats formule exactement comme toi
ça va on peut passer à la journée
d'après donc là on a une preuve qu'ils
ont falsifié un document avant de le
publier
aaron hill a raison si je peux me
permettre la raison c'est ouvrir la
porte à de gros problèmes à l'épaule à
jour des statuts nous finirons la main
exactement interest et d'options chez
toi oui je crois je tâcherai d'en
ramener touré pape les a menées par
l'ong a dit un jour [ __ ] j'ai été voir
juni hier soir il lui restait des gens
nous et il ya ces notes que j'ai prises
au cours de ces trois dernières années
j'ai retrouvé un feuillet chez moi mais
le reste est est ici sur mon bureau j'ai
l'impression caravane à tous rangés dans
les archives il va falloir les retrouver
nous mêmes comme les journaux un [ __ ]
jorge montes aurier et bim même qu'on
n'a pas vu c'est la même réunion [ __ ]
c'est une fan réunion faire et
d'anguilles ont simplement éviter une
centaine de personnes la honte et la
victimisation entraînerait la
publication tout en révélant à faire on
ne touche pas aux documents
on lui rend tels qu'ils sont mais je
donne un texte explicatif her2 positif
influence pas l'opinion du lecteur pour
commencer interprété sans influence est
impossible aaron et ensuite
personne n'a besoin d'un livre des
victimes du quai on a besoin de la
confiance des lecteurs
c'est grâce à ça que tu n'as pas 25
procès sur le dos si on commence à
toucher aux documents qu'est ce qui
pourra assurer la fiabilité
comment veux tu qu'ils sachent que la
liste a été retiré enfin georges
n'auriez peut-être tu penses vraiment
que jorge montes auriez très heureux de
ce bar médiatisés comme cela il fait
partie de la famille d'une des victimes
et le contrat que nous avons signé avec
1000 stipule que me qu'ils ont pas son
nom en tant que source
personne n'ira vérifier qu'il est et des
dénonciateurs d'accord effectivement pu
les la liste des mecs qui sont fait
arnaquer vulgairement c'est un peu
millions pour eux moi je suis d'avis à
modifier le document dans le sens là on
modifie pas ce qu'il affirme on retire
une partie pour éviter à des gens des
t'emmerder d'être humilié donc ouais
faut détruire le nom du mec qui a lancé
larnack crochet à tapant procès on avait
des choses là nous avons dû faire face à
notre premier procès ne l'avons gagnée
alors on assure que ce sera le dernier
l'équipe en doute l'acquittement ce
soutien public que nous le devons
l'homme qui nous a attaqués a été
pendant un temps le plus détesté du pays
la prestation collective vaut parfois
mieux que toute la fortune de mon frère
heureusement pas d'eau car on il a pas
tort dans le sens à [ __ ] c'est
compliqué ça a bondi à blanc auxquels
ils font face sans kenol un extrait de
cette réunion mais de quoi tu peur de
perdre l'opinion publique et non pas de
la perle qu'elles suffisent que nous
protéger
à partir du moment où je ne peux plus
plier mes propres documents je m'attaque
à des cercles beaucoup plus large et
surtout plus actuelle les dossiers de
mon père pour cerner tous des événements
passés depuis au moins un an et malgré
ça nous avons quand même dû faire face à
un procès nous n'avons aucune structure
défendable c'est uniquement d'un soutien
public et à la mauvaise image qui ne
risque est que leur plainte a été
retirée
mais si nous publiions des affaires
de la semaine d'avant dans l'action ne
sera pas la même
c'est de ce genre de questionnement dont
nous avons besoin on peut trouver
quelque chose en rapport
c'est super dur là en tapant jamie des
choses et on à la suite de la réunion le
nous mettons tous en danger dans cette
affaire qui mettait aussi en danger la
première publication
mais le projet n'était pas connue
qu'est-ce que ça intéresse ça dort au
moins faire la centième fois que je
l'entends cette conversation à une
semaine bon et me donne moi cette
feuille que je l'écrive cette lettre je
suis d'accord et en publié et mis du
nôtre
nos documents s'épuise le numéro que
vous tenez entre vos mains sera le
dernier du genre le revenge ne s'arrête
pas à battre mais sa poursuite des
réformes
entièrement de vous envoyez nous vos
dossiers
tout ce qui vous indigne tout ce que
vous voulez dénoncer tout ce qui sera
vérifiable sera publié nous garderons
notre impartialité et les sources
garderont leur anonymat
tu mettras d'une forme pour la lune ami
avec l'adresse d'une champ que je
louerai pour recevoir les dossiers sans
les envoyer qui a tenté de combiner
plusieurs mots pour affiner les
recherches carles est non non pas du
tout et c'est une excellente idée à ta
pension saron je te vois sur un truc le
dossier d'intéressant mais il laisse
entendre que mi6 grande verte fox on
aurait fait bien plus en un mot il est
incomplet j'avais compris y est tu dois
retrouver la source
autrement la source je ne retrouve pas
les sources
rudd pour faire une famille c'est violer
à peu près tous les principes du rivage
qu'est ce que tu voudrais que je fasse
je vais pas publier un dossier incomplet
souvient de l'époque où tu aurait
abandonné le dossier où tu l'aurais
publié en précisant qu'il y manque des
éléments où tu n'aurais pas été stupide
hop hop hop eichhof petit aaron hill a
un peu en difficulté quoi il veut
vraiment que son journal soit comme ils
le voient soit parfait complet et cetera
il en vient même à violer ses principes
[ __ ] aller fin de journée jeunesse du
ventre et voilà nous avons tous les
journaux que l'ess n'avait jamais déposé
aux archives
ce sont les derniers normalement oui et
pourquoi cette radio une émission qui
parlera du revenge est prévue
aujourd'hui vraiment là on avait arrangé
il ya quelques mois un coup de publicité
toujours bon pour l'image publique
oui je suppose que ça vaut le coup qu'on
écoute on allume la radio ok bienvenue
dans votre de la 4c rafale berne qui
vous paraît le plus jeune auditeur on a
entendu parler l'émission d'aujourd'hui
sera consacrée à l'histoire du albanese
brit air jean la new yorkais qui fait
tant parler de lui depuis quelques
années si l'émission est prévue depuis
des mois la nouvelle est venue
bouleverser son cheminement
vous n'avez pu passer à côté il ya
quelques jours que l'intégralité de
l'écriture events a donné sa lettre de
démission à nous il ya le rédacteur en
chef
howie juni schmitt y manquait un truc
qu'on n'avait pas su adams je suppose
que ce serait le bon moment pour nous
révéler ce que vous attendez que je tu
vas faire d'inscrire de nouveaux persos
création le suspense est insoutenable
nous pourrions passer un accord disons
donnant donnant les sorties vers changé
d'avis sur votre sincérité et en échange
vous pourriez nous aider à gagner
quelques mois l'annoncé démocrate qui
vous ressemble et rohart exemple bien
envoyez moi quelque chose a publié avant
vendredi
ça sera fait je ne désire pas m'attarder
au revoir monsieur james o o laborde m
adams rémy nous n'avons qu'à dévoiler la
sphère du ps
ouais nous étions présents et nous avons
laissé faire à rendre tout ce qu'ils
voulaient mais nous avons toutes les
preuves pour prouver qu'il a
délibérément menti mensonges dont nous
sommes les complices nous pouvons
trouver mieux crois moi tu nous a
cherchés ça c'est paraboles mort en
prison et y avoir brisé avec l'urd qui
est cet adam thiam on va savoir là on a
une autre partie de ce moment de faire
tomber dans le froid est-ce que c'est
une tactique politique où cet homme est
définitivement stupide normale et
justine nature et qui de toute façon
aurait envie de voter pour nous dit
pareil
moi j'ai voté pour eux tu as quoi voter
le jour d'adams mais quand qui apportent
leurs idées de ce foyer intéressante est
allé une fois que je ne savais pas qu'il
ait tourné défendra en toute façon qui
ne le fait pas beaucoup de gens arrêtent
adams était malchanceux et ou
malchanceux d'avoir dans ses rangs de
cana patronne est offert
tu voudrais voir oui pourquoi pas je
rêve
tu sais voir j'ai voté pour eux dès
qu'ils le droit de le faire car oui
c'est ce qu'on appelle un droit j'ai
respecté la transparence absolue en
intervenant à l'heure de publication des
documents
je suis ravi et les mêmes vieilles se
battre l'antiquité la sphère du ps
comment ça vous agace et une si petite
affaire ne devrait pas prendre trop
d'importance monsieur adams menace de
nous tailler une image de menteur il n'y
a rien de pire pour aaron donc le mec
qui fait de la magouille avec de la
politique ce qu'on offre de chatr boxe
comme le relate journal j'ai tapé procès
revenge si jamais pour trouver des infos
tour d'un procès que l'on élira son
opinion publique
on a besoin c'est elle qui nous soutient
qui nous maintient en vie qui nous évite
les procès et la censure tu sais qu'il
est allé trop loin cette fois non nous
avons discuté
la raison je me demande si des procès
n'en a pas mais va lui tu ne pensais pas
différemment à cette époque et humide
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé [ __ ]
chatterbox bim bim
allez on trouve deux trucs en est chaud
là tu ne peux pas dire ça il ya
clairement quelque chose que tu dois
résoudre avec aaron et ce n'est pas
parce que châteauroux box gros
fiançailles de juni que tu ne peux plus
franchir le cap avec lui je ne vais rien
franchir du tout avec aaron tu veux me
faire croire qu'il n'ya rien d'entre
vous je ne veux pas être avec cris mais
tu ne veux pas que les autres pensent
qu'il est avec juni istore damourette ça
ça c'est de l'histoire d'amour est ça
parce que personne ne sait quoi
personne n'a jamais été confronté à ça
tient la route à quoi cette ambassade en
ses fiançailles ça c'est un torchon
bientôt son entrée de jeu tu sais à
merde voilà propre journal qui annonce
et les finales des fiançailles du mec
oui en tapant fiançailles qu'escompte
aux moutons sur ça tu veux pas m'en
parler il va bien falloir que tu en
parles un jour au moins que tu sortes
ça va faire une semaine qu'on ne t'a pas
vu aller vraiment brad basse cajon va se
fiancer avec john salter box office
aulas en bateau ou en tapant fiançailles
à rome on a un truc là démons dire ce
que j'attendais ça publié là bas donc
pas si simple évidemment l'opinion des
violences et les vignes où ils ont
besoin de l'hôpital un accord mais
qu'est ce que tu préfères tu es lecteurs
ont peu de respect ouverte aux mêmes à l
epr est un mythe hollister co
est ce que quelqu'un songe à la jeunesse
et l'enfance heures je n'en sais rien un
vote pour changer ça me bats c'est
facile
alors quoi mon dieu à rené l'opinion
publique
la démission aura au moins eu le mérite
de libérer juni de ces faux science haye
trappe [ __ ] ce hard core quoi le mec
pour gagner des points auprès des gens
ils prêts à mythos quoi il n'y a pas de
quoi être et d'injustice mais y'a de
quoi le le briser dont les gens comment
pourrait-on recouper les informations
des notes des journaux et les interviews
j'en suis à huit leur rival jeunes
importe quoi germé à la suivre cette
conversation là quelques revenge a tout
fait pour que tu puisses gratter un truc
elle doit enfin les dunes houtkerque
oui le nouveau sur doit forme je ne
comprends pas tu trouvais ça
rambur pas ça fait des semaines il
fallait bien quelqu'un fasse edwards
ford nous parle bien des mêmes mafieux
sans matsui qui est mort je m'attendais
bien à ce que papa nous quelques secrets
à cacher au cours de sa carrière n'est
parce qu'ils étaient entassées au fond
qu'une bureau parce que tu penses que
c'est vrai si nature le tampon tout
qu'est ce que tu comptes en faire le
donner à la police qu'elle aille
chercher ford aux enfants d'amérique
centrale c'est les autorités ont
contacté papa à l'époque pour qu'ils
décident d'une affaire et maintien
d'abbas en baisse en 10 c'est qu'ils ont
passé un accord avec ford
voilà de quoi inculpé la famille où les
âmes fin on devrait peut-être revoir
quelques jours nous pour être certaine
de ne rien oublier
mais dis moi ce que je voulais je vois
pas que je perds mon emploi à cause de
toi en tapant vrai j'ai eu simple il
démonte istres est un bon moyen pour une
transparence
et puis est ce que c'est vraiment grave
à dire que j'attends hoekstra n'importe
quoi en classe à cologne a démenti passe
presque toujours pour un mensonge alors
qu'a subie à cela avec le sourire en
coin un sourire d'adolescent timide et
félicité que j'étais en boxe pour son
école ainsi la leçon donnée ça ce serait
ducati
est ce que c'est vrai quoi donc je
remets toi vous êtes ensemble vous avez
à revenir gare dire ex card est atteint
comme à l'abri en mode hésitante bon
[ __ ] ça me suffit pas moi c'est ça la
sq il nous faut maintenant c'est là on a
deux documents et y en a un troisième je
sais pas quoi taper pour le trouver
[ __ ] au en tapant publié je suis tombé
sur la partie qui nous manquait [ __ ]
j'en peuple vous avez publié des
documents sans vérifier l'exactitude dit
la source
ah c'est ça qu'ils ont fait mais l'une
services secrets se trompent une fois
sur deux dans ce genre de manoeuvre bien
j'ai été trahi
vous avez été trompée et après pourquoi
pas essayer de nous courons pour qu'on
publie pas les documents si vous n'avez
rien à vous reprocher alors c'est
généralement plus simple pourquoi alors
n'avoir pas cherché à nous rencontrer
dès la publication des documents
pourquoi but de décrédibiliser auprès
des électeurs c'est mon dernier recours
on approché jamais votre cible la vraie
raison
s'il y avait une raison n est pas en
mesure de l'exiger
[Musique]
les amis cela fait maintenant près de
deux heures et demi que je joue à ce jeu
vidéo je sens à travers ma pipe qu'on
est à sa de découvrir le problème c'est
que monsieur adam cela il ya un [ __ ]
de scandale
il faut gratter quelques voix
d'électeurs en demandant à rentrer de
mettre un petit coup de plus dans son
journal pour lui mais on sait pas
pourquoi on sait pas ce qui a en a fait
de mal pour que lui puisse demander ça
j'ai trouvé trois ou quatre vidéos de
2,2 cette scène il doit manquer une ou
deux et [ __ ] j'ai marqué tous les mots
de la langue française mon gars je
trouve pas bon en tout cas merci d'avoir
regardé toute la vidéo je dis ça veut
dire que l' enquête vous a plu et que
vous vouliez élucider le truc comme moi
même si on a fait j'ai adoré enquêter ça
montre que j'ai pas que j'ai pas les
capacités pour résoudre les enquêtes
dont je vous invite à télécharger le jeu
crois que coûte 5 euros 1 tout comme ça
et à essayer de résoudre le truc j'ai
pas réussi je suis dégoûté j'espère que
inspecteurs squeeze aura des élèves qui
dépasseront le m n'hésitez pas à mes
deux ça vous a plu si gentil que vous
plaît puis et puis voilà que la vidéo
est tellement longue que la dram en est
plus que dix toute manière la regarder
foulée dix mecs de faim je vous kiffe
alerte rouge et noir et regardez
vingtaine ou bien désolé de la foire et
géo tout le monde piste
[Musique]